hey noah what up hey okay first and
foremost how are you feeling after
getting your tonsils out
[Laughter]
i got mine out at 16. it's a serious
operation when you get older
that's no joke man it hurts
i feel great though it's like i had i
had these
huge tonsils and so they're gone my
throat still has like scabs but
it's healing up really nicely it only
hurts when i yawn and uh
you know it feels clear and hopefully i
uh
i won't get sick as often nice have you
been eating a lot of ice cream
you know not really more ice cream than
i have
than i usually eat for sure but still
not a lot not a big
yeah oh that's good that's probably good
um you know i just
absolutely loved this third film it
wrapped up the way that i i wanted it to
you and lana just have such fantastic
chemistry um what are you gonna miss the
most about working with her
um i think how comfortable it felt
you know i feel like just working with
her feels like um
i don't know man it's like diving into a
warm pool or something i don't know it's
like
you know it's like nice easy it's she
gives so much
um you know and and the the world
to all the boys is just such a fun world
to play in
um i think i'm just gonna miss i'm gonna
miss that i'm gonna miss that
comfortable feeling
um but at the same time you know i'm
ready to do other projects that are way
less comfortable
yeah and kind of step out of the zone
which is scary but also exciting right
yeah yeah yeah i'm very shocking too i'm
trying to go crazy
yeah well we know that you've been
working out like crazy
have you worked out with dwayne johnson
yet for black adam
i haven't but i can squat more than him
my one rep max is actually more than
dwayne johnson's right now
wait wait wait are you serious i don't
know
would you want to work out with him or
is that like way too intimidating
i'd love to he'd kick my ass probably
jeez
you imagine i mean it would be cool i
would just do it for social media just
to be like oh my god this happened
dude the dude can probably like bicep
curl me if i just like held on he could
just bicep curl me
it's true it's very true but i would
watch that video i'd want to see you
guys do like
a working out video together with dwayne
and noah but he's just using me to work
out
okay now you gotta make this happen oh
my god this is brilliant
yeah we've come up with a good plan it's
gonna go viral um
you know for you being on these films
it's been a part of your life for so
long now
what has it meant for you to be a part
of the to all the boys world
man it is it has enriched my life um
you know to no end in so many ways i
think
you know it's brought me to different
different countries in different cities
to work
so i've been able to see the world um
and even like if you're doing
press and promo you know it brought me
to brazil um so the the traveling aspect
of it has been incredible
um it's brought me and my team closer um
it's given me more experience as an
actor working on different sets with
different people
um it's opened so many doors you know
with projects that i'm now
looking at and reading and people that
i'm able to meet and creatives
um you know i think it's connected me
with
a large audience of people that i never
would have been connected with before so
i can
kind of like gauge what interests are
for those people
and um yeah i mean it's just it's
enriched my life in so many ways i mean
even just from like a place of security
you know in my own life you know not
worrying about survival
you know anything like that it's just uh
being able to take care of family
members you know there's there's so much
you know that uh that it's given me that
you know i'd never really be able to
repay i
i don't know it's it's a blessing i feel
very privileged you know i'm very very
lucky
i love that and just wrapping things up
any plans for valentine's day
not really just this
[Laughter]
do you eat chocolate are you a chocolate
lover ah not really not really no but i
do
you're not into the sweets i'm not into
sweets i like crepes though
get me a nutella and banana crepe and
we're good okay good to know thanks so
much see you later